four surprising to some earning a job
here in the opening game on the second
line a blast from the point
and it is
[Music]
first for the Brads who score just a
minute two in
[Music]
CH well keep her Sherwood just going to
the front of the net Randy and it was
just a quick shot from that right side
point good hard work in the corner and
Ferraro loses a stick and that's the
reason why keeper Sherwood is able to
get to the front of the net and right
there that shot comes through off of the
skate in on the scape of
looks like classic as he was in front
with keeper and then he just is able to
knock in the back of the net to get the
scoring started for the national
predators Sherwood's fifth year in the
NHL started with Anaheim in fact Bay
News debut back in 2018 with the Ducks
against San Jose bounced around a little
bit spent last year in the American
Hockey League where he was dominant and
he comes through with a big early goal
here for the predators in their first
period of the season